the family of a patient who became
pregnant and gave birth while in a coma
at a nursing facility is speaking out
for the first time they say they're
traumatized and shocked by what they
called the abuse and neglect of their
daughter the 29 year old woman has been
in a vegetative state for more than a
decade she gave birth last month at
Hacienda health care facility in Phoenix
Arizona the woman is a member of the San
Carlos Apache Tribe police served a
warrant yesterday yesterday to get DNA
from all male employees at the facility
a lawyer for the woman's family issued a
statement on their behalf saying the
baby boy has been born into a loving
family and he will be well cared for the
chairman of the San Carlos Apache Tribe
tells CBS News quote I am deeply shocked
and horrified at the treatment of one of
our members and it is my hope that
justice will be served
hacienda CEO Bill Timmons stepped down
yesterday the business as it is
committed to doing everything in its
power to bring the police investigation
to a quick conclusion and those DNA
tests the science will find the answer
tell the story that's right we need an
answer to that very disgusting story